hi guys and welcome back to city
skylines in this episode I want to talk
a bit about the let's play itself but
before I had into that just want to give
a small introduction of why I actually
do in this episode game wise I decided
to just make a couple more living
districts in the style that I already
had and also kind of experiment with
Dutch black blocks to see if I can
actually make some neighborhoods with
that in the future and also try to set
up a business park alongside the highway
to see how that will actually go but the
main thing I actually want to talk about
in this episode and the reason why I'm
actually recording this episode as well
is the fact that the last video the that
is the first video of this series
actually got posted on the nether or the
Netherlands subreddit which was the last
thing I ever expected if any of my
videos to even happen but it was posted
by somebody by the username golems so
thank you for that because as a result
the video got a lot of attention from
people who know more about that city
building than I do which is very good
because I got a lot of useful feedback
and suggestions from that thread the
only thing is that I can't really do
much with it since the first five
episodes of this let's play were
actually recorded in the Christmas
vacation and when I decided to lock
myself up in my room all alone and
listen to music and play city skylines
so I can't really do anything with these
suggestions as of yet I'm very happy to
have them though and I'll start actually
trying them out and changing the city
eventually and tweaking some smaller
major things based on suggestions that I
get the same goes for YouTube comments
by the way but I can't really do it as
of yet so the first five episodes are
all already predetermined and you can
still get feedback on them but keep in
mind that I'll actually go into tweaking
this city based on that feedback in
episode six or maybe a little later but
episode six is where I'm currently at as
I'm speaking so that should be alright
but yeah this episode is pretty not too
special so far just continuing to build
the city in the sort of way that I
envisioned so far I wanted this entire
part of the city to be this more modern
Dutch look which I suppose you either
hate it or love it I for one I'm not too
big of a fan of this style because as
much as it is actually fun to make it
and it looks cool from the ground it's
very repetitive and the row houses are
very repetitive as well it's pretty
boring style to live in but it's the arm
sort of road pattern which is very
popular in the Netherlands for a newer
areas so that's why I wanted to get that
in here and I'll actually branch off
into the other road styles at some point
in the future so far the only real ways
in which I've done it is in this more
modern style and the infamous
cauliflower is style which is the a
little bit older style from the 70s and
80s where most roads are just completely
as quickly and kind of confusing or at
least nuts the um that's the bad way to
short story for it and the long story
will come in the episodes when actually
get to that but so far I sort of wanted
to continue building the city in this
way since it's a very easy way to get
things done and you don't really have to
worry about too many other things like
standalone houses or curved roads
because you don't really have it too
much much of this type of layout is
actually quite straight just not in the
grid like way that most American cities
are but it's a very easy style to build
I think so that's why I wanted to start
it off like this I also wanted to get a
little bit into foliage over here as you
can see and also these little plants on
the side I have to admit actually and
this is probably the worst thing that I
could have done that I don't actually
have the after-dark DLC so I don't have
the bicycle paths
I'm planning to get it but I have been
planning to get it for the last couple
of months and I still don't have it and
I should probably get off my lazy bum
and actually get it because especially
for this type of city it's probably
necessary but for the moments I'm just
kind of using those pedestrian paths
that you just now saw to at least
emulate the sort of idea of having these
bicycle lanes next to the roads which
you see around nearly all of the roads
in the Netherlands and
so we took something to come back to
actually is that in last video I talked
about two main types of roads in the
Netherlands which was actually almost
right I didn't really base that on any
theory or anything but it turns out that
the Netherlands actually makes a
distinction between three different
types of roads which is very similar
though where they make the distinction
between the very small roads that you
use to actually move around inside the
living areas with the row houses then
there's the more transporting roads that
actually connects parts of the city and
then the more outside roads like
highways or national roads and things
like that which actually can connect
cities and you know as you just go steps
into this road system you can drive
faster but you also have less services
along the roads that's the sort of idea
that you have so yeah I got that right I
suppose in the over way in which it
works somehow but it wasn't entirely
exactly the way that it's used in real
life so I'll try and actually use that
in the future and that's actually where
I think the main difference is going to
be from episode 6 onward because so far
what I was doing was really just
emulating the Dutch style of road
building but to be very honest my
understanding was in two large it was
really just experience from Google Maps
a bit of Wikipedia and Road wiki's and
real life of course but not too much
going into the theory of building roads
itself which is something which I do
plan on getting into after episode 6 and
that's why I also want to start tweaking
some little things there are definitely
some things which I either forgot or
procrastinated and had our very Dutch
elements two cities that I don't have
yet like I I'm not going to spam small
shopping malls or shopping streets in
the next five episodes which is
something that I should have done in
hindsight just to make the city look a
little bit more Dutch what you often
find in Dutch cities is that the each of
these living areas each of these small
row house neighborhoods they usually
have one small shopping centre in the
middle of them with with my
the basic sort of shops so maybe one or
two clothing stores a supermarket and
some really necessary things like a
bakery which is something which I didn't
do yet so that's something that I want
to get back to in two week in Episode
six and also spamming schools is
something which I should have done in
hindsight but it's really that sort of
thing which I want to move back to in
Episode six and look back on what I can
improve in the city and this over here
actually is why I try to get that flat
block neighborhood in and I was pretty
much forced to actually use these
ex-communists flat blocks are multiple
flats on them the workshop you don't
actually get in these black box in the
game itself but the ones on the workshop
are pretty good but they're all sort of
from ex-communists countries which is
one of the main issues that I have with
it so even though it gets the shape and
overall form of the Dutch flat blocks in
there it still looks very much like it
is from a communist country there's just
not too much I can do about that I'm
just gonna have to roll it and see how
well I can actually make it look touch
the only real thing that I have to say
to myself in hindsight of building this
little flat block over here just to test
what sort of buildings I need and how I
could set it up a little bit is that I
should probably set it up a little bit
wider and have the flats further apart
from each other and definitely have a
couple of parking lots here and there
which I actually forgot and that space
and now over here is where I actually
wanted to get the Business Park going
but to have it in this entire Road part
over here would be a little bit too
large so I figured I would actually
having lit have a small living area
still next to the business pike and sort
of divide this space into two parts and
have the row houses on the left and have
the Business Park on the right next to
the highway and that's why I quickly
wanted to still fill this in with houses
this is also something which I might
change a little bit in the future if
only just because the transition from
Business Park to housing area right now
is very very sudden and there's no real
transition between them and that's
something which I do wish to get in the
future maybe just put a small park in
between them
and go from there oh and some feedback
that I would just now like to talk about
about last video is that the time-lapse
is actually very fast the first episode
and this one as well because this one is
already pre-recorded and I removed the
original video files because they're way
too large
I still add twelve times the speed of
the gameplay which is very fast and
actually got a couple people saying it's
a little bit too fast and I spin around
a lot and I don't think I'll change the
latter since I just like to play the
game this way
and sort of pretend that nobody's
watching and just moving around makes it
easier to see how things will actually
look but I will slow down the time
lapses to about eight times the regular
game play speed I think if that's still
too fast you can always sort of leave a
comment about that I suppose and I'll
see how I can change it but this video
is still the last one that's going to be
quite fast and move around a lot so if
it makes you dizzy I'm sorry about that
I'll try and adjust that for the future
I'm sort of used to rollercoaster in
three I suppose in which I at least move
around a little bit less because there's
not because there's a lot more that you
have to do in the UI with that game
which is why I'm sort of used to
speeding up gameplay twelve times but
I'll see how much I want to slow down
for this game and this over here is
actually a good point to come to as well
this is the theme manager for everyone
for anybody who doesn't know the there's
actually a mod using which you can
create your own themes and put buildings
into certain themes that you select a
district and say what theme the district
should have and they automatically get
only buildings of that theme in that
district so that's how you kind of get
those row houses automatically the row
house is actually only workshop with the
models and the theme in one bundle so
you don't have to actually make the
theme yourself but when it came to this
business point over here I wanted to
make sure that I only got the office
buildings that I actually wanted to get
in there so that's why I wanted to
select the buildings myself with the
theme manager and just make it a little
bit more easy to get the exact buildings
that I wanted I granted in the end it
still took me a lot of time to actually
get the exact buildings that I wanted
especially and without getting rep
because I wanted to avoid having these
same buildings all over the place I mean
eventually when it comes to the entire
city you can't really avoid having the
same building spammed multiple times all
over your city sounds realistically
there just aren't enough models in the
game or even in the workshop to get an
entire unique city but I want to come as
close as possible and at least keep the
same buildings as far apart from each
other as I can just to create the
illusion that every building is a unique
building so that's why I wanted to mess
with the theme as well and remove
buildings as soon as it was a building
that I already had in a way and the last
thing that I wanted to do over here with
the business Pike is actually actually
add a little bit more foliage to it that
church as well since I figured I wanted
to at least add a bit of scenery to it
and not leave it completely empty or
make it into a complete forest foliage
is also still something that I would
like to return to on later occasions
especially when it comes to anger on
shrubbery or making the forest a little
bit more dense at some places but over
here I just wanted to get a bit of
simple foliage in the sort of Business
Park way not to dance and a couple of
different trees and some ornamental
foliage as well and decided to actually
play some rocks in there eventually just
to be a little bit more of a scenery
touch it was actually quite hard to find
the exact sort of scenery that I like
the the thing which I could have done
honestly is to actually use fences as a
ornamental scenery item throughout the
city but the way that fences work in
this game is just quite painful they
don't snap to each other so you kind of
have to rotate rotate them exactly the
way in which you want and they also have
a hitbox that's larger than the fence
itself and it's kind of a bit too
annoying to work with I think to
actually use it in this case so just
wanted to quickly add some works in
there to make it a little bit better and
especially when it comes to these
roundabouts
I just love adding little foliage and
scenery touches to roundabouts and get
some unique scenery to each round
but yeah that's pretty much about it for
the time lapse I didn't have any
real-time footage recorded for this
episode I won't have that for too many
episodes to be honest but I figured and
then instead I would actually get these
flying camera route shots here too so
you can kind of see what the city looks
like especially from the perspective of
the city itself this is also why I think
the graphics actually pretty good
especially with the Sun ray and ambient
occlusion and dynamic resolution mode
this by the way is that Road which sort
of functions as the main nerve of the
road system in the city where I want to
attach all the roundabouts which should
eventually be able to actually hold all
of the traffic which goes to the city so
far
speaking from episode 5 in which a large
part of the city is already finished I
don't have too many issues with it so
I'm really not too worried about having
these roundabouts over here and their
capacity I think they're large enough to
sort of take the capacity that they need
also what's funny about these buildings
over here actually is that I didn't have
to replace these buildings at all they
came out in this perfect color scheme of
brown brown green green red red and like
they did that out of themselves I
actually didn't have to replace any of
them which is the biggest coincidence
actually was planning on getting it
exactly this way and I just randomly
placed some zones over there and I got
it exactly the way I wanted to which was
actually very funny and I have no idea
what the odds are on that but I'm sure
they're pretty small and then this is
what the living areas look like from a
aerial perspective and you can see the
three render distance kind of glitch
over there which is annoying but I do
like to buy this looks in general anyway
that's it for this episode so thank you
guys for watching and have a good day I
suppose